Welcome to the Ann and Ashley Show.
I'm Ashley, and I'm Ann, coming at you live
from Connor's Clinic.
Be sure to subscribe, like, and follow our social media
pages and these videos for more episodes.
In today's episode, we will be discussing EMS,
what they are, how they affect their health,
and ways to reduce our exposure.
So Ann, what are EMS?
So a very basic explanation of what EMS are,
so you can think of them as invisible energy fields.
Really, it's a magnetic field or an electric field
that is emitted from devices.
So it can be from cell phones, from computers,
from gaming devices, and really from any household appliance.
So yeah, I was really shocked to see that a hairdryer,
a hairdryer is one of the worst offenders in emitting EMS.
And so it's really kind of scary what you think about
drying your hair every morning and putting it obviously
close to your head.
That is terrifying.
Yeah, limit the use of the hairdryer.
What your hairdryer or hairdryer wants to a while
or just try to not use the dryer the whole time.
Yeah.
Get your hair halfway done and might not be good for styling,
but you're protecting your brain.
That's very important.
So that's kind of a very basic description
of what an EMF is.
There's an infographic where you can see kind of the spectrum.
So there's a spectrum on the low end.
You have longer wavelengths with a lower field,
and then you get all the way up to kind of the shorter wavelengths,
which emit a higher frequency or a higher magnetic field.
And so the ends of the spectrum are thought
to be damaging to us as humans.
In the middle of the spectrum,
there's visible light.
Visible light is not harmful.
So again, it's just kind of when you get outside
of the visible light and you're entering into one ends
of the spectrum, that is considered harmful.
Can be harmful to human health.
Yes, and the cellular structure and our chemistry
gets all damaged and messed up too from these EMFs.
And there have been several research studies done
on just that.
So there's been studies by the World Health Organization
on EMFs and your cell phone
and putting it directly up by your head.
And that has been linked to gliomas,
with the radiation just in that spot
on the same side, the phomas being used on.
And you're up there,
have been studies on different leukemias for adults
and children linked to specifically EMFs.
There have also been studies done
on our neurological and psychological health as well.
Negative effects on how it affects our mood
or our sleep and several other symptoms.
And then, of course, 5G is not even been researched yet.
Very little, but that's been a topic of interest lately for America.
And that's kind of scary.
Not to have any research back that up.
And they're saying that it's going to be on that gamma ray
danger zone for EMF exposure,
but it'll be so light that it's a long-term effect.
And so we won't know how that's going to affect us
against our nose-resilation, human guinea pigs.
Yes, by the way, which gets really scary, because yeah.
So yeah, it's going to be everywhere.
Right, and so awareness, of course.
So we should probably make that part three of this video.
Because I think that would be your part.
Yeah, three part video now.
But yeah, there are symptoms that come with EMFs.
There are so many of them.
There are a lot.
And a lot of people experience a number of these symptoms.
So it can be anything from chronic fatigue, brain fog,
to nightest, so the ringing in the ears.
Lack of concentration, the ADD, which
is rampant in the schools today.
It can joint pain.
It's linked to being nauseous.
Inability to handle stress.
In today's society where everything is so fast-paced,
we have high amounts of stress constantly.
So EMFs can directly correlate to inability
to handle stress anxiety.
So EMFs are affecting our sonomitocondrial level.
And so the moods, which you talked about,
are a huge thing.
So anxiety, depression, fertility, as well as people
on that seems like there is more and more infertility
happening.
And so how much do EMFs play a role in infertility?
So all things that play a role.
Yeah.
And so ways to help reduce your exposure
to hopefully reduce those symptoms
would be to maybe shut off your white eye at night
when you're not using it.
Put yourself on an airplane mode at night if possible.
Keep it away from you when you're sleeping in the same room,
maybe across the room, in a different room, whatever it might
be.
So you're not constantly getting exposed to it
when you're sleeping.
Also going outside in nature and going for a nice walk
will help ground you, picking up maybe cool looking rocks
to put in your pockets during the day
so it can attract the EMFs to the rock
and not to your person.
A jewelry is very popular now with stones.
So maybe wearing some type of stone, holding on to a stone
when you're on your device, putting a distance between you
and your device instead of putting a laptop directly
on your lap, put a barrier between, especially
that fertility.
Yes.
Topic as well, that's huge.
And then plants and salt lamps.
If you have those around your home,
that would be a great thing to start utilizing.
Smart meters are very popular now without consent.
To see if they're just going to move in.
I don't know if you're going to have people.
So the dangers of those and what room it is emitting directly
on, it's very important.
So maybe giving that room some more extra attention
with salt lamps or plants or something along those lines,
you can also eat rich antioxidant foods.
Yes.
So the colorful rainbow on your plate.
And then you can also put aluminum foil around your smart meter
if you choose to.
It may blow away in the wind.
No guarantees on how effective that would be.
But there are products coming out to also assist us in protecting
and reducing our EMF exposure, especially with maybe 5G.
So what can we do in that area?
So yes, there's a lot of things that we can do
if we want to take it to the next level.
So obviously, these things that Ashley just talked about
are things that you can just implement right now.
Just being aware and making a conscious effort to try
and get away from some of these exposures
we're never going to be able to take all EMFs away.
But just reducing the exposure is the goal.
So everything that Ashley said, if you feel
like you're highly sensitive because some people are,
you can even take it to the next level.
There's things that you can do to protect your home.
There's things that you can apply to your devices
to protect the fields from your devices.
And there's things that are supplements.
There's just a number of different things
that you can do to just kind of take it to that next level.
And that's what we're going to talk about in episode two.
So we're really going to dig in, get into an inquiry
of how a lot of these things work
and what you can do to have protect yourself
in your loved ones.
On part two.
And then part three.
And now we just decided that we need a part three on the IG.
So definitely stay tuned.
Again, please like and subscribe to our Facebook page.
We have a YouTube channel as well.
And share these videos with your loved ones.
Because certainly, we hope that this information is helpful.
And then hopefully, you are inspired
to share with others to help protect your loved ones.
Yes, of course.
So thank you for watching.